it's winter in southern chile home to
the alerse or patagonian cypress one of
the world's two oldest proven tree
species
that's where we meet up with
environmental scientist jonathan
barichivic from the university of paris
in the alessi national park a unique
temperate rainforest
he actually grew up here when his
grandfather was a park ranger
he was the one who discovered a new
challenger to the world's oldest
recorded non-clonal tree
a four thousand eight hundred fifty
three-year-old bristlecone pine in
california
but ichivich is taking us to meet
great-grandfather the nickname of the
alerse he estimates is almost
5500 years old
but first he demonstrates the
traditional method for determining the
age of trees by using a special drill or
increment core to remove a five
millimeter sample the length of the
tree's radius here is you got a a core
where you can see three rings as like a
uh barcode this then you transform it to
two numbers then with this number we
build models of how the tree grows
unlike satellite data that goes back no
more than 40 years trees reveal earth's
environment as far back as prehistoric
times
but ichivich argues that the past can be
used to predict future climate change
more accurately the core of a tree is
something like a book it tells the story
not just of the tree but of the whole
area in the last decades hundreds of
years or thousands of years
to read it you can look at the rings
these for example show that it was a
plentiful year they're very separated so
it means there was a lot of rain the
ones that are much closer indicates that
those years were of drought and over
here you see the scar of the tree this
means that there was a fire
but dentro chronologist antonio lara who
recorded a three thousand six hundred
twenty year old alersif thirty years ago
says in
tourism is endangering the survival of
these trees whose roots are already
dangerously exposed from erosion this is
a younger alersi tree and it was someone
that we don't know who a couple of weeks
ago came and you can see here like with
a machete or something like that took
out the the bark we don't know why
because this is pure vandalism
as a result the park is now temporarily
closed to the public but the forestry
service made an exception to allow us to
see great grandfather for ourselves
perched deep in an isolated ravine it's
an imposing majestic sight to behold
from its four meter wide trunk
to its enormous exposed roots
the longest instrument available isn't
long enough to reach the tree's center
to determine its age with the
traditional method so barichivitch has
devised a mathematical model to fill in
the gaps but some dentro chronologists
aren't yet convinced i think that it's a
bit hard without having actual ring
counts of the trees it's we cannot
really say that it's
definitely the oldest we can
of course say that it is amongst the
oldest trees in the world
but ichivich will be publishing a paper
later this year defending his theory the
great grandfather is indeed 540
years old but i'm not worried because
this is science for the planet
it's science that make us to act on time
to protect
what
is left of a planet that was once
completely wild
he insists the challenge is to use
ancient trees to improve climate models
to determine how forests might adapt to
our changing conditions
the same forests on which the future of
humanity also depends
lucia newman al jazeera los lagos region
chile